quindici anni di canale 15 anni e dire
che tempo fa avevo detto che avrei
mollato ai miei 30 anni invece adesso
sono 33 anni i miei e 15 del canale
quasi metà della mia vita passata a fare
vivere e devo dire che poco è cambiato
nella mia testa per quanto riguarda
qualcosa che vedo è che voglio
raccontarvi siamo in un periodo in cui
youtube è un po stanco non a livello di
contenuti ma proprio a livello di
pubblico sia un po stancato diciamo
hanno perso l'attenzione hanno perso
lavori è di andare a cercare nuovi
canali nuovi video ma secondo me le
persone che fanno i contenuti sono
rimaste identiche a tanti anni fa e io
sono rimasto lo stesso che appena vado
in un negozio e vede una cosa che mi
piace la compro perché so che sotto
sotto ci potrebbe essere qualcosa da
raccontare e questo video è una di
quelle storie le una storia partita da
un dubbio la storia partita da una
curiosità nel chiedersi semplicemente ma
che cos'è quello perché nessuno me ne ha
mai parlato perché nessuno me l'ha mai
consigliato e perché lo sto comprando e
sto mettendo nel lettore e perché l'ho
visto e perché adesso mi voglio parlare
e perché grazie a questo ne ho comprati
altri e ho scavato su queste case di
produzione e adesso ci devo fare un
video perché non c'è meno funziona così
da anni e non riesco a staccarmi dal
trash perché ho comprato il gioco da
tavolo di cultura vederla cosa sta
succedendo
[Musica]
come potrebbe mai iniziare una mia
storia se non con un acquisto il
paradiso può attendere cosa stracazzo è
il paradiso può attendere e la stessa
cosa che mi sono chiesto io quando mi
sono ritrovato questo tipo di fra le
mani e un dvd che è stato venduto al
basso prezzo di 5 euro e io l'ho
comprato usato a quattro quindi non è
stato neanche un acquisto così ponderato
è così intelligente tra l'altro è anche
bucata la custodia perché uno dovrebbe
guardare questa locandina e decidere di
comprare questo dvd di questo cartone
animato perché di questo stiamo parlando
semplicemente dalle voci che doppiano i
personaggi si parla di ezio greggio enzo
iacchetti francesco facchinetti il luca
argentero cosa mi stai dicendo perché
certa gente
ve lo spiego subito questo cartone
animato è un piccolo progetto del vv.f
c'è un giorno si sveglia e dicesse cosa
dovremmo fare oggi dovremmo far scrivere
un intero film animato a dei bambini
leggendo libretto si evince che oltre
4000 classi della scuola primaria e
secondaria hanno partecipato al concorso
è solo una ha vinto e la cosa buona
uscita da questo progetto e che è un dvd
per aiutare i boschi perché parte del
ricavato andrà a tutela dei boschi
italiani quindi dovrei andarci anche
leggero visto che è una cosa anche a
favore della natura solo che cercandolo
in giro io non ho trovato nulla
niente ci sono sporadici articoli nel
web e su youtube ci sono due trailer uno
leggermente più lungo dell'altro ma che
sono fondamentalmente lo stesso solo uno
più riassunto e uno meno riassunto e tra
l'altro il paradiso può attendere molto
sfortunato come titolo del che esiste
già un film molto più famoso con lo
stesso identico titoli e quindi quando
tu anche volendo andare a cercare sul
web troverai quasi esclusivamente
informazione su quell altro film è come
se io ritrovassi il filmino del mio
compleanno di quando avevo tre anni lo
vendessi in dvd nei negozi e lo
chiamassi matrix non va bene e come
questo dvd e
strano parla di questi di questa
riunione condominiale nel paradiso degli
animali estinti che decidono di
insegnare all'uomo
quello della salvaguardia degli animali
estinti insomma la solita solfa per i
bambini
con questo dato è questo orso polare
bianco insieme a questo bambino cercano
di salvare il salvabile è tutto così
ritmicamente sbagliato è difficile da
spiegare perché se vi faccio vedere un
frame non è così malvagio ma se me lo
faccio vedere animato c'è sempre
qualcosa che non va un un frame mancante
un ritmo di battute sbagliato come se
mancassero delle pause tra un dialogo e
l'altro è difficile da spiegare se non
l'ho provata in prima persona ed è
strano che queste cose finiscano sempre
nelle mie mani ma perché è come se io
fossi destinato a parlare di queste cose
qui ma e finendo il film che vengo
colpito da uno schiaffo fortissimo
quando leggo il nome del regista orlando
corradi
avere ora si spiega tutto
[Musica]
io vorrei sapere di chi di voi non
conosce la mondo tv questa azienda di
produzione e distribuzione di film e
cartoni animati fondata proprio da
orlando corradi nel 1985 magari se vi
ricordo che la sua mascotte un
barboncino bianco chiamato winner dove
però nessuno e vincitore in questa
storia come dicevo prima sono tra le
case italiane di distribuzione e
produzione più prolifiche del mondo si è
prelevato creato talmente tante serie tv
di cartoni animati ed i film di cartoni
animati come sissi il libro della
giungla sì quel libro della giungla
cartone ma ti che ho adorato nella mia
infanzia tipo papirus oppure la pimpa
lupo alberto però adesso facciamo un
gioco
io prendo il frame un singolo frame di
un cartone animato di una serie animata
è in voi dovete indovinare da cosa è
tratto
ecco qua questo è il frame e vi faccio
vedere anche qualche secondo vi do una
grande mano con le fece vissuta
non riuscite proprio a capire
strano perché così palese che sia la
serie animata di un medico in famiglia
avrei detto la piccola bottega degli
orrori no è un medico in famiglia ma se
non mi interessano queste cose qui non
vi preoccupate perché tanto la mondo tv
ha comprato e distribuito ho prodotto
lei stessa una miriade di serie tv e
film su gesù e succedanei ovviamente
come non dimenticarsi della serie
animata in 3d su giovanni paolo ii karol
ma voi siete qui per un altro motivo voi
siete qui per vedere le mie sinapsi
esplodere e infatti voi siete qui per
bentornato pinocchio il
seguito di pinocchio non lo conoscete il
seguito di pinocchio fatto dalla mondo
tv dove avete vissuto e una fluidissima
continuazione della storia originale di
carlo collodi dove lui alla fine del
film salvan natale 6 power ranger hanno
salvato il natale è in chiesa hanno
salvato natale perché non può pinocchio
prima di continuare vorrei ricordarvi
una come ho detto prima la mondo tv non
solo compra a dall'estero e distribuisce
questi cartoni animati ma li produce
anche in casa e uso le virgolette perché
la maggior parte di queste creazioni
originali le animazioni vengono fatte
fare dallo studio sec e se vi ricordate
non ci ha parlato nel video di adrian e
questo studio nord coreano che crea
cartoni animati lo studio set da loro è
diventato famoso per aver creato una
serie animata sulla guerra con gli
animali e quali persone migliori ci sono
di uno studio nordcoreano che fa una
serie animata per bambini con propaganda
militare per fare il seguito di
pinocchio ma lo studio sec è
involontariamente diventato famosissimo
in italia per aver creato la leggenda
del titanic illusi voi che pensavate che
il titanic fosse una storia vera no è
una leggenda infatti questo secondo la
mia modesta opinione è l'unico
lungometraggio che racconta la storia
vera che è quella che quando il titanic
se diviso a metà stava affondando e
stavano morendo centinaia di persone
arriva un polpo gigantesco chiamato
tentacoli know con una faccia da
schiaffi e salva tutti ed io e altre
migliaia di persone ci abbiamo creduto
così tanto a questa storia che hanno
addirittura fatto un seguito sul polpo
chiamato tentacoli know ed è pura e
semplice follia
ci sono elizabeth dom swan che decidono
di farsi aiutare il dato in tavolino per
andare nelle profondità marine e tipo
acqua man in questa civilità stranissima
che mi ricorda ripeto sott'acqua nella
minaccia fantasma per ritrovare il
titanic io non so più cosa reale e cosa
no aiuto perché soffermarsi a
distruggere le fiabe della nostra
infanzia quando poi disintegrare anche i
classici disney dissero alla mondo tv
sai cosa manca il re leone sai cosa
manca al re leone uno spin off su simba
è nato un re e facciamo quello che nel
re leone manca una bella battaglia stile
fosso di helm e non vi preoccupate non
c'è bisogno di avere questo splendido
dvd a portata di mano per gustarvelo c'è
suprime libero sai cosa manca simba sai
cosa manca assi ma uno spin off sul
figlio su sì ma junior facciamo che
winner la mascotte in modo tv viene
rapita e sembra junior e ai suoi
fantastici amici viaggiano a new york e
facciamo quello che mancava in simba
scoiattoli fantasma laser e lanciafiamme
sai cosa manca simba junior sai cosa
manca simba junior diventare una star
del pallone simba junior e non sto
scherzando che dio mi fulmini re del
football e facciamo quello che mancava
simba junior winner nel frattempo dopo
essere stato para pitto a new york è
diventato un allenatore di calcio per la
coppa del mondo animale e via ecco una
clip di simba junior che fa una
rovesciata come ibrahimovic
no
[Musica]
sì
se c'è una cosa che mi dà un po fastidio
delle custodie di dvd classiche e la
loro poca portabilità dovrebbero
inventarsi una custodia un po più
maneggevole un po più versatile nella
sua portabilità sia di giorno che di
notte qualcosa che possa anche andare
bene con il mio outfit diciamo parliamo
un attimo della bimbo cartoon è una di
quelle case di produzione e
distribuzione esattamente con la mondo
tv che tutti quanti sicuramente abbiamo
beccato nei negozi nei mercatini o
addirittura nelle vecchie librerie
durante il trasloco che dice lei mi ero
dimenticato di avere questo meno male
che hanno fatto queste pratiche maniglie
perché altrimenti non avrei avuto nessun
modo per portare questi dvd per questo
grandi bill e dunque qui della bimbo
cartoons abbiamo mulan e anastasia
partiamo da mula è un cartone animato
normale generico sottomarca che se ne
trovano tantissime ma quando si parla di
ciofeche animate non si parla soltanto
dell'interno del contenuto ma si parla
anche della presentazione del packaging
come possiamo vedere l'immagine
principale non solo è tagliata ma anche
la scritta del logo di bimbo cartoons
risulta completamente mozzata mentre la
frase principale frontale quella che
dovrebbe venderti il prodotto dice
testuale parole il costumi e le
tradizioni d'oriente stupiscono per
l'eccezionale varietà di loro
di nora a mentre se noi passiamo dalla
stasia possiamo notare infilando il dvd
nel lettore dvd già dal primo freno
quale sia la casa di produzione che ha
fatto questa è la digos e la dingo e io
a 33 anni pensavo di aver superato
questa fase della mia vita e invece
eccoci qua vorrei soffermarmi sul
destino di una piccola ragazza perché
anastasia tutto bene tutto a posto in
famiglia mi sembri un attimo stanca
vatti a fare un sonno e soprattutto la
chicca delle chicche la neve nel menu se
il tuo aspetti un secondo
finisce che esce a un certo punto la
ghiffa animata della neve smette di
continuare non riparte il loop e rimane
un menù triste solitario ma se queste
custodie dovessero risultare ancora un
po troppo ingombranti per mori o una
soluzione il
dalmata 2 questo cartone animato sempre
della digos è un mini disc o mio dio il
cane nel menu
per caso la tua padrone anastasiano
pensa bene solo che ogni tanto passano
anni dalla visione di queste cose qui e
soprattutto dai bivio che ho
precedentemente fatto e mi sono detto
non l'ho già affrontato questo argomento
non l'ho già visto questo film sì vi
ricordate no dal mission 3 quel gioco
della prigione dove ci sono minigiochi e
poi il film della lingua ma sono lo
stesso film in questa linea temporale
dalmata 2 e dal mission 3 sullo stesso
film tu vuoi che ti manda affanculo
perché poi io non riesco a fermarmi
capito non riesco a fermarmi e quindi
vado a scavare nella mia libreria in
camera in casa e mi ricordo di aver
fatto altre cose di avere altri giochi
dell'apri 2 della tim con dentro altri
film di toys vi ricordate per aver
parlato vi ricordate ne avevo parlato vi
ricordate e come se non bastasse
direttori su me esiste anche il dvd con
solo il film senza i minigiochi chiamato
boys boys room and toys sono lo stesso
film ma con quei nomi e due locandine
diverse e dinosaur l'adventure e lo
ricordate dinosauri della dingo picture
certo per lo ricordate il mio canale
esploso grazie a quei vicoli e non avete
mai smesso di chiedermelo quando tornano
le recensioni sono passati tre anni da
quando ho smesso di farle di quando le
facevo ma è ancora tutto quei è ancora
tutto qui e là bimbo cartoon non sismica
fermata lì o no è piena zeppa di dvd che
cercano di entrare a far parte
dell'infanzia di un bambino ma i bambini
sono più intelligenti di questa camelot
di questa sirenetta sono più
intelligenti e inutile che voi fate
cercato il vostro mercato sono le
segnare io so che sono le zingare che
loro dicono il bambino dice vorrei la
sirenetta e poi vengono a comprare ma
non è più così non è più così connessi
xoom prime con londra non è più così qui
c'è la sirenetta che appena fin fine il
dvd nel lettore partono il trailer
perché non sanno neanche programmare un
dvd come si deve e poi un generico
camelot tu immagina di essere seduto per
terra il giorno di natale davanti al tuo
65 pollici in feliz questo dvd e vedi le
grafiche dei menu che sforano
completamente e scattano come se stesse
cercando di farlo partire su windows nt
wi fi parti del film e viene aggredito
visivamente da un filmato in full motion
vino di un attore che ti urla in faccia
e per amore del signore che cosa cazzo è
quella roba lì vi ricordate quando uscì
aladino con will smith che faceva il
genio che tutti si incazzano perché will
smith genio è un po strano la computer
grafica era così così poi è uscita la
gente bene o male l'ha fatto passare
ecco non è questo quella lavino li
possiamo zoomare un attimo sua lavino
per vedere che hanno cercato di dargli
una conformazione fisica umana ma
purtroppo questa intelligenza
artificiale non sanno bene come ci ha
fatto un umano e il genio della lampada
e homer simpson e homer non ho neanche
una battuta da fare e homer simpson blu
e infortuni ci provi sempre ci provi
sempre a mettere questo maledetto dvd
nel lettore dvd e sperare di essere
anche solo un minimo intrattenuto ma no
nemmeno si può vedere aladino che pensa
ad un altro aladino sono disegnati in
due modi completamente diversi a chi
devo credere che sono i miei punti di
riferimento quindi nel marasma di
informazioni tutte frastagliate ti
chiedi chi sia la bimbo cartoons chi si
celi dietro questo splendido studio di
distribuzione beh cercando su google e
non esiste più il sito c'è scritto
addirittura che è stato sospeso che
questi minuti della bi bo cartoons non
venivano quando voi andate magari nei
mercatini dell'usato quando c'è qualcuno
che vuole vendere uno stock intero di
cartoni animati di dvd di cartoni
animati
in mezzo c'è sempre qualcosa che ti
frega
e in questo caso sono
[Musica]
le fiabe in dvd potrebbero sembrare una
brutta idea ma dipende da quanto
tecnologica e la vostra famiglia perché
sai da tanti anni da da praticamente
sempre le fiabe sono qualcosa che tu
racconti sai che un adulto racconta ai
propri nipoti ai propri figli ai propri
fratellini per farli viaggiare per farli
sognare insieme a te per stimolare la
fantasia
diciamo che un dvd con una fiaba diventa
un pochino più sempliciotto ma
ovviamente sono io che ho dovuto trovare
questa cosa qua
questo è il dvd della fiaba del brutto
anatroccolo una classica fiamma per
bambini e diciamo che a parte una
locandina di dubbio gusto visto che
graficamente le fiabe sono in un modena
copertina in un altro tutto funziona per
il verso giusto per errore ho comprato
un altro dvd del brutto anatroccolo il
primo e della epic artour o av film tv
rimette questo e della super collection
av film dvd e dello stesso identico menù
del dvd prima ma com'è possibile come è
possibile che la stessa identico di
movimento distribuito in due versioni
diverse con due collezioni diverse con
due copertine completamente diverse ma
perché non volete farmi capire un cazzo
allora sono andato a cercare la voce ma
ho detto magari mi darà qualche risposta
e lav film distribuisce di tutto dai
cartoni animati ai grandi classici agli
erotici come clockwork oggi è il sito
ufficiale anche qui non solo non è
disponibile
ma è anche non sicuro ma potrebbe sempre
sempre andare molto peggio
signore e signori qui per voi o una
delle locandine più belle della storia
dei film in dvd non avete mai visto
niente del genere non avete mai visto
una composizione fatta in questo modo
magari questo tipo di qualcuno ce l'ha
in casa ma nessuno si è mai accorto
dell'inestimabile valore intrinseco che
a questa locandina signore e signori vi
presento bob la quaglia
[Musica]
siamo tornati là bimbo cartoons e come
potete vedere nonostante il nome di bob
la quaglia nella locandina abbiamo due
topi non ho sbagliato stampare non ho
tagliato nessun bordo è esattamente così
come la vedete sono due topi stressati
se zoomiamo un attimo sulla mano potete
notare che lui tiene quella che
sembrerebbe essere una lente
d'ingrandimento o una padella dipende
dai punti di vista come potete vedere
l'autore ha deciso di appoggiare con la
mano al bordo della locandina uno dei
due topi quello con il cappello ma il
punto forte di questa locandina e questa
linea che separa l'immagine dei topi con
l'immagine di quella che sembrerebbe il
deposito di paperon de paperoni
palesemente tagliato perché non è lì
loro hanno pensato di metterlo lì come
se i topi avessero trovato un tesoro ma
in realtà possiamo notare le monete
tagliate dalla linea a metà ma la
ciliegina sulla torta che chiude il
tutto è che questo tesoro è capovolto al
contrario signori e signori
bob la quaglia e come sarà all'interno
secondo non è bob la paglia non sono due
topi bob la quaglia è una quaglia ma è
il cartone animato di una serie animata
che non c'entra nulla né con la
locandina né con i topi ho cercato mari
e monti per capire che cosa fosse questa
locandina e sono contento di potervi
dire che l'ho trovato esiste un altro
cartone animato che in europa è
conosciuto come i topi poliziotto
esistono varie versioni di questo film
tra cui una con i due topi in copertina
da noi purtroppo è arrivato sotto forma
di gioco della playstation 2 con un
altro tipo di copertina e quindi siamo
di fronte a una delle più grandi truffe
visive al costo di 50 centesimi ma se
pensate che questa sia la più grande
truffa degli vivi i cartoni animati non
avete ancora visto johnny il bar bottino
che diventa grande la storia del crudele
barbablù e dei suoi segreti del castello
ma non era giorni ma la marmo tale
cresce la storia del cattivo barbablù
che donava le proprie mogli tutte le
chiavi del castello chiesa e che se
chiedi giorni apro la custodia e della
stessa sede di prima e giorni il marmo
chino delle da grande la stessa serie di
quello di fob la quaglia non si sono
neanche degnati di cambiare il
millimetro di carta dell'immagine del
dvd ma comunque cosa cazzo c'entra
barbablù con john di 15 anni di canale
per arrivare a questo punto della
viabilità grazie mille per aver visto il
video e noi ci vediamo alla prossima
[Musica]